Harry we come now to chapters 12 to 14
which continues in some ways what Paul's
been talking about which is the gathered
life of the community in the discussion
of the very beginning of first
Corinthians you pointed out that what
are the things Paul thanks God for is
the spiritual gifts of the Corinthian
community and now we have three chapters
where he's talking about what spiritual
gifts are and how that affects their
communal life what's going on here mm
well it goes back a little bit to the
remark that we made in the last chapter
talking about being in a worship setting
where there's a sense that you're
participating in the heavenly worship
worshiped by angels you know I think
some people in the Corinthian
congregation trying to to manifest that
I thought they were manifesting it by
speaking in a language that was
unintelligible
folk folk in the community and exactly
how they got into this state and what
they were doing and what the language
sounded like we have no idea but they
were speaking in an unintelligible
tongue as a sign of their spiritual on
down there and I think Paul finally
objects to this and says you know on the
one side I can understand it here again
as always he speaks to both sides of the
debate he says I can understand this
phenomenon I do it myself yeah
but at the end of the day it's not to be
preferred all things might be possible
but not all don't have bones right oh
and well we have to take into account
here he says we have to discern the body
you can use the language after 11:00
again and the body is the assembled
group of believers and whatever we do in
that worship assembly has to build them
up and it also has to look beyond the
boundaries of that worship assembly and
it has to make sense in some way to
people outside of wonder in so just
doing things for our own
self-satisfaction to build up myself to
puff up us that to use a language that
he deploys earlier on the letter that
won't cut it or the Christian worship
assembly so that's the the basic issue
here and as in chapters 8 through 10
where he was dealing with the issue of
eating meat sacrificed to idols here he
gives us an excursion chapter and I'm
stuck a sandwich you have that's right
speaking in tongues speaking
chapter 13 and that the the sandwich is
structured in the same way affirming on
the one side and then calling a
digression on the other yeah but in the
center there's this this this framing of
a fundamental value of virtue and in
this case it's love yeah and we have
this marvelously poetic chapter on it's
not about weddings no it's not though
I've used it off it in that it always
comes up and it's entirely and you can
make it work useful yeah weddings yeah
that's not what I was talking about
living in community and that that that
love of the neighbor and community has
to ground everything else that we do
including what we decide to do for
worship so he before getting to that
though in Chapter 12 he deploys let me
just do one quick thing on that yeah and
as far as the wedding things exactly it
for years I did this though I speak in
the tongues of people and of angels and
thought what a lovely rhetorical kind of
Shakespearean flourish but that's the
point but the point is even though I
have angel language which is the
speaking in tongues stuff but don't have
love that's not if so I've that that
really it very much is the topic
sentence not a rhetorical flourish to
get going exactly okay very much so
after 13 verse 1 you know it ties it in
very nicely but the argument that he
deploys in chapter 12 is interesting to
remember in Chapter 11 he had been
talking about the bomb discerning the
body and discerning the body and there
was a an element of the communal layer
people had to wait for one another and
take one another into account as well as
an element of the symbolic eristic body
well here he uses body language again
and what we pointed out and earlier on
when he was talking about how women
should behave in here in worship he
deploys an argument and then corrects it
we see something similar going on here
because he deploys the body image in
chapter 12 verse 12 following in such a
way is to recall the kind of rhetoric
that you get in greco-roman political
context there's a famous chapter in the
Roman historian Livy about a revolt by
plebeians in Rome that was counted by
senatorial patrician who said to the
plebeians we are all part of one body
this is a fellow named Ananias
and I said well even though we said it
does look like the belly and you guys
look like the feet and the arms we have
to hang in there together you feed us
but we never shoot yeah all right so
there's that that use of it which is a
kind of hierarchy yeah easy for the
belly to say right now Paul in deploying
this this image talks about the
mutuality of there all of things he
emphasizes mutuality very much very much
which was quite interesting so all the
body parts have to hang together that's
very much what he was saying in the
previous chapter about discerning the
body but he also wants to correct that
and here in a hierarchical way in
Chapter 12 verses 27 and following why
because his concern is with the way in
which this spiritual gift speaking in
tongues is to be a value and so he says
there are different gifts and graces in
the church different charisms and at the
top of the list stands apostles and then
prophets and teachers and what's the
bottom air people who do deeds of power
Healing forms of assistance and forms of
leadership that's where I stand as a
Dean right and then various kinds of
tongues are really down so Paul wants to
make sure that people understand that
this particular spiritual gift is not
the most a genuine gift but but very
much qualified by the others just one
thing that strikes me about that is that
that absolutely this is a metaphor
absolutely this is image it's it's it's
also that body spirit magical thing
we've talked about that when Paul talks
about churches body of Christ to other
places that comes up in the Epistle that
have always struck me are one we didn't
talk about this warning men not to go to
prostitutes because when they do that
when a Christian male is part of the
body of Christ has intercourse with a
prostitute Christ has intercourse with a
prostitute and that's blasphemy and that
when a believer has intercourse with an
unbeliever the unbeliever is sanctified
by that because body of Christ is making
love to non believing person it's just
immediate is a metaphor it is an image
but it's also somehow
particularly realistic - it's an
embodied spirituality and we're very
serious seriously in ways I don't
altogether comprehend but it's strong I
think okay so one of the things that
Paul is insisting on here is that there
has to be orderly worship yeah and that
there's a hierarchy in the way that this
operates preaching to be more important
tongue speaking this tongue speaking
stuff and the preaching has to be
intelligible to those inside of that so
that's all but and then all of a sudden
bingo in chapter 14 verse 33 and
following we have Paul saying that women
should be silent yeah yeah doesn't this
contradict what we heard back in chapter
11 where women are talking away where
the only issue is what women should wear
should wear on their heads this is one
of this is one of the few places where
I've been persuaded by the argument we
love to use which is that the bad Paul
is not the real Paul I mean it goes back
to my kind of interpretive clay and then
when in doubt check the good Paul and
use it to to qualify the less good Paul
this it's not this is not just good Paul
bad ball this doesn't sound like Paul at
all this sounds like it's wandered in
from somewhere else what do you think I
think that's right and it's interesting
that these several verses appear in
several different places so there's a
little wonder and then you also have to
see why it's placed there because in the
next verse verse 37 anyone who claims to
be a prophet on where spiritual powers
must acknowledge that what I am writing
to you is a command of the Lord
so in effect by having that little bit
there which stands out like a soil
yes context which is all about orderly
again is there because it's it's being
grounded in a command of the Lord not
simply in Paul's own opinion yeah so I
think what's happened is that some later
scribe and the Pauline tradition who has
like many people in the church adapted
to greco-roman norms and wants to keep
women in their place takes this this
passage wherever you got it and sticks
it wonderful opportunity to put that in
there yeah yes a way of ground to get
the name oh I think that's writing of
Jesus that's right
so what Paul's really interested in is
Cle
from verse 38 and following right be
eager to prophesy and do not forbid
speaking that's a great line how many
yet all right all right if you must
speak in tongues but prophesy absolutely
and then what Presbyterians love that's
right he said exactly exactly it's the
story of a whole Presbyterian life
mm-hmm each thing do something in an
order